Male 1: Color, style, comfort, utility, and
convenience.
These are the ultimate desires of today, tomorrow
and the years ahead of us.
Lines, forms, and textures and colors to give
to us beauty, charm, and elegance.
Female 1: Each year, New York's Museum of
Modern Art holds a Good Design exhibit to
show the public the best in current design
for modern living.
Female 2: Oh, I like that one.
Male 2: We were committed to the mass-produced
chair.
It would be a good chair and it would show
that it was mass-produced.
Female 3: This one can be covered in any number
of interchangeable materials.
Male 3: Good evening.
The television and radio stations of the United
States are proud to provide facilities for
a discussion by the two major candidates for
the presidency.
Male 4: The new 500 is an entirely new car
of modern design and construction for thousands
and thousands of new motorists on four wheels.
Male 5: Let's see. Good design and,
and good materials and then finally
good craftsmanship.
Female 4: The wall lamp which becomes a table lamp is what seems to interest our host
at the moment.
The lamp demonstrates what is so true of the
whole exhibit.
Function combined with good taste results
in good design.